So we were talking about your treatment at the hands,
let's say,
of Western feminists.
And like I read infidel,
I dunno,
very shortly after you published it,
which,
and I,
I love that book man.
As soon as I read that I thought,
well,
I used,
yeah.
And I thought it was remarkable.
I thought your comment on your comments on viewing Western culture from the
perspective of an immigrant that was how refer for genuine education and,
and your comments on your,
your experience with the efficiency of the Dutch state say,
and you're sort of amazement at how well it worked.
That was just,
I thought that was so remarkable and clearheaded and I thought when I read
infidel I thought,
well,
this woman is immediately going to be a hero to feminists everywhere because
she's removed himself from this oppressive state and moved out into the world
and become a powerful figure when,
what was the probability of that?
It was like zero,
you know,
and that you suffered as a consequence of your beliefs and you stood up
forthrightly for them.
And I thought if you wanted to find a feminist hero that you're certainly,
you're,
you're certainly in the running man for exactly that.
And then to see how you've been treated.
It's just,
I just,
it just makes my jaw drop.
You know that your dis,
especially what Brandeis did,
it was Brandeis right where you were offered an honorary phd and then they
revoked it.
That just,
that was one of the,
I think that was almost as reprehensible,
inactive cowardice as the West's basic abandonment of Solomon Rushdie after the
fat,
what was put on his head and about equally dangerous.
So
it was multicultural.
I mean,
what I,
you know,
my message,
my life story,
who I am,
it's a defiance of the prevalent trends of today.
It's against the law.
I believe that Western values as superior to Islamic law and Islamic values,
not to say that is to blast being in the temples of multiculturalism today.
And so I think,
I hope we did a lot of people because it wasn't about what they think should
happen for victims of misogyny.
I think it's all about the dissonance that my words and my,
my life and my beliefs,
the kind of decisions they put these women in.
Because if you're going or I'll say,
well it's horrible to be an American woman and then the surgeon in America is
worse than that.
No it's not right yet.
I,
I'm sort of interfering with their,
with their worldview.
The claim that you're making there is something like this and it's really,
it's a really vicious claim in a sense and it's something like the western
feminists who are possessed by postmodernism and cultural relativism are willing
to sacrifice the freedom and equality of third world women in places like Saudi
Arabia to maintain the sanctity of their multicultural notion because that
justifies their attack on western patriarchy they're willing to use.
Okay,
so that,
that's an absolute pause.
Oh immigration.
There are so many men who are coming from these societies that at us men that
they're not used to the equality of
women inside the West.
First of all they're all women,
child marriages,
female genital mutilation,
honor killings.
But now we have these crepes and sexual harassment of non Muslim women and these
women keep on arguing for more integration and they didn't hear anything
negative about some of the negative impacts of immigration.
I don't consider them feminists anymore.
I think that there are so much more uh,
committed to preserving their world view,
their post modernist worldview than they are to the heights of
well that's what it looks.
I mean I think like that,
that's how it looks to me is like this is the situation with Saudi Arabia is the
one is the test case is like,
so you might say are the postmodern feminists types are the ones who present
themselves as that,
are they more concerned with the rights of women or are they more concerned with
bringing down the so called tyranny of the West?
And the answer is they're more concerned with the ladder than they are with the
former.
Because when you put them head to head,
those dispense with the rights of women across the world.
As long as they can maintain their moral justification for the radical bleeps.
And I do think that is why they go after you because you're,
you're exactly the reprehensible exemplar of what it is that they're attempting
to deny,
I would say,
and I think that does show their true motivations.
Absolutely.
Out of time.
I'm getting a lot of signals here that I should,
I should hang up now,
but I,
I really enjoyed talking to you and I hope that in some way I've contributed to
to the message that you want to get out of there.
You know what,
I'll stop with this.
I'll give one 30 seconds.
I'll just tell you what,
what are doing with this?
I mean I have arranged with a group of moderate Muslims in Canada and some in
the u s as well to start a series of dialogues like the one that we had today
because this isn't really viciously important problem and so I want to use this
as the opener for that.
I would like to go after this issue of whether or not a real dialogue could be
begun between the Judeo Christian West and the Islam world with some hope of not
having all of this devolve into endless and continual warfare.
Because as far as I can tell,
that's where it's headed.
Yes.
That's where it's headed.
Yeah.
Well,
I hope we'll get a chance to talk again.
Thank you.
So,
okay.
All right.
Yup.
Bye.